well joining me now to discuss this in a
bit more detail former senior
intelligence and security officer Philip
Ingram so Philip let's start by talking
about the tanks is getting all the
headlines well the latest on the
discussions about donating these leopard
twos it is well this discussion is going
on day 334 of Vladimir Putin's 10-day
military operation and we're still
talking about leopard twos
um Chancellor Schultz spokesperson has
said today there's been no official
inquiry from those other European
nations that have leopard two tanks and
say they want to transfer them in
particular Poland and Finland
um I think Paul and Finland want to get
a coalition will Germany actually
um donate some of its tanks as well but
um Chancellor spokesperson said we
assume that other parties will follow
the prevailing law when they put their
application in however the polls have
started training ukrainians on on the
tanks and it's that training bit that is
that is important and
given the you know the fact that some
countries are willing to hand them over
Germany remains to be seen we thought
that decision would be taken Friday at
that big meeting of foreign ministers
but it didn't happen and when should we
expect to see some of these tanks arrive
in Ukraine because uh Vladimir zielinski
has reminded the West countless time
that that time is of the essence
essentially it is but there's no point
in the tanks getting into Ukraine until
the crews are ready to use them and
operate them and putting it into context
and it's it's slightly different but um
the British Challenger 2 and the
ukrainians have already started or
starting this week to be trained and
Challenger two if you take a newly
trained British Army soldier and put
them onto the standard course to teach
them the basics of that it's a 20-week
course now that's a that's a peacetime
course it's going to be accelerated for
the ukrainians because they will send
their most experienced tank crews in to
to learn about this so that'll be
compressed very quickly indeed but not
only do they have to learn to operate
the tank those maintainers need to learn
how to maintain it and then they need to
learn how to fight it with other the
tanks and with other infantry fighting
vehicles and other bits and pieces so
it's quite complex so getting the tanks
into Ukraine at the minute we've got
several weeks before the ukrainians are
even going to be in a position to
operate them and use them um that gives
plenty of time for this political
machinations uh to be sorted out yeah
highly pressurized situation what does
all this mean for the spring offensive
because that's what Ukraine are getting
ready for yeah we keep hearing about the
spring offensive and everything that's
going on and there's sort of three areas
that people are focusing on the thing
that's going to drive it is the ground
whenever the ground
um is hard enough for those heavy
armored vehicles remember the British
army the Challenger tours over 70 tons
to be able to get across it so it's not
going to be early spring it's too boggy
there are three areas that we're looking
at talk over the weekend around the
zapparisha area the the Russians are
concerned that
um the ukrainians are building up the
ukrainians are going to try and attack
down and split this land bridge that
they've got from Crimea the whole way
through the ukrainians do that the
Russian defenses could collapse
completely further up in the north North
East on cremina the ukrainians are
pushing in through here and having some
small successes and the Russians have
built some defensive lines to the south
of criminal and the hallway around their
their lines the Russians are building
layers of Defense with all the fighting
at the moment going on around back mode
um and bakmut um has you've been
fighting for that for the last six
months or so um however I think the
ukrainians are effectively fixing the
Russians in place there so they're
focusing on that that's allowing the
ukrainians to take some of their more
experienced Crews and send them off to
be trained elsewhere okay Thank You
Phillip Ingram there